ONE OF THEM, CHARLES SMITH,
WOUND UP HAVING TO DEFEND
RODMAN.
HERE'S MORE OF IT RIGHT NOW.
>> WE RECEIVED A LETTER FROM THE
DPRK OLYMPIC COMMITTEE ON
INVITATION TO DO THIS GAME.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT DENNIS -- I'M
SORRY.
DENNIS -- LIKE I SAID, I DIDN'T
LIKE DENNIS.
I COMPETED AGAINST HIM.
WE WERE NOT FRIENDS.
AND OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS,
WE BECOME BROTHERS.
I MEAN, WE GO OUT ON THE ROAD
AND WE HAVE A GREAT TIME
TOGETHER.
WE DO A LOT OF GOOD STUFF.
BUT UNDERSTAND THIS.
UNDERSTAND THAT HE IS NOT HERE
AND I AM NOT HERE -- NONE OF
THESE GUYS ARE HERE TO TALK ANY
SENSE INTO ANY POLITICIAN AND TO
HAVE ANY -- OTHER THAN
BASKETBALL DIPLOMACY WHICH I
FEEL IS ABOUT HAVING A
RELATION -- UTILIZING THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH OTHERS IN AN
ACCOMMODATING WAY THROUGH
BASKETBALL WHICH WE DID TODAY
WITH THE NORTH KOREAN TEAM.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR.
DO YOU REALLY THINK THAT THE
LEADERS ARE ARE GOING TO LISTEN
TO WHAT WE HAVE TO SAY?
WE'RE NOT HERE TO DO THAT.
WE'RE HERE SPECIFICALLY TO PUT
SMILES ON PEOPLE'S FACES.
EVERY LASTING MEMORIES IN THE
MINDS OF INDIVIDUALS.
AND HOPEFULLY, WITH THE GOOD
WORK THAT WE DO, WE GIVE TO
CHARITY WHILE WE'RE HERE.
AND WE'RE JUST GOING TO BE AN
EXAMPLE TO HOW WE ARE AS
AMERICANS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SPORT OF BASKETBALL.
SO PLEASE, DON'T CONTINUE TO PUT
POLITICS INTO THAT.
>> I GET IT, CHARLES.
THE PROBLEM IS IT'S MORE
COMPLICATED THAN BASKETBALL.
IT JUST IS.
>> YOU SAY -- YOU KNOW, AND YOU
SAY IT'S MORE COMPLICATED THAN
BASKETBALL.
BASKETBALL IS NOT COMPLICATED TO
US AND THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
WE'RE NOT IN HERE FOR
COMPLICATIONS.
AND AGAIN, WE APOLOGIZE FOR WHAT
HAS KIND OF THE STORM THAT HAS
BEEN CREATED FROM OUR PRESENCE.
WE'RE NOT APOLOGIZING FOR DOING
WHAT WE DO.
WE'RE CONNECTING PEOPLE TO
BASKETBALL AND PEOPLE TO PEOPLE.
>> I GET IT.
THAT'S ALL GOOD CHARLES.
>> ALL RELATIONAL.
>> THAT'S ALL GOOD.
>> YOU SAY YOU GET IT, BUT
THAT'S ALL WE'RE DOING.
>> BUT THE GAME HAS BEEN
PRESENTED -- THE GAME HAS BEEN
PRESENTED AS A BIRTHDAY
PRESENT -- THE GAME HAS BEEN
PRESENTED AS A BIRTHDAY PRESENT
TO THE RULER.
I'M NOT HERE TO FIGHT WITH YOU
GUYS.
I RESPECT WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
I'M CONCERNED FOR THE FAMILY OF
THIS MAN WHO IS HELD THERE.
AND I'M CONCERNED, AS MANY MERPS
ARE -- AMERICANS ARE, GIVING A
BIRTHDAY PRESENT TO A MAN WHO
JUST EXECUTED HIS UNCLE.
>> YOU CAN CONTINUE TO TALK
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT AT THIS
TIMES THAT IS -- ACTIVITIES THAT
TAKE PLACE HERE.
WE HAVE -- THERE'S ACTIVITIES
THAT TAKE PLACE ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
WE ARE USING BASKETBALL AS A
BRIDGE FOR CULTURAL EXCHANGE.
AND THAT'S ALL ABOUT
COMMUNICATION.
WE'RE NOT -- AGAIN, WE'RE NOT
HERE TO DEAL WITH THE POLITICS.
THE DATE OF THE GAME IS THE DATE
OF THE GAME.
IT WAS ARRANGED THAT WAY.
WE'RE HERE TO DEAL WITH PEOPLE.
NOW, LET ME GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES.
WHEN WE SPOKE TO THE NORTH
KOREAN PLAYERS TODAY THROUGH THE
TRANS LAY TORS, THEY ASKED US
QUESTIONS ABOUT PROFESSIONAL
BASKETBALL, THEY ASKED US
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW WE LIVE,
THEY ASKED IS QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE GAME.
WE INTERACTED WITH THEM.
WE REPRESENTED OUR COUNTRY IN
BASKETBALL.
AND WE ARE VERY PROFESSIONAL
ABOUT IT.
THE FANS AFTERWARDS SAID THINGS
LIKE, WE HAD NO IDEA, YOU GUYS
ARE RETIRED, YOU GUYS ARE OLDER,
BUT YOUR SKILL IS SUPERIOR AND
YOU TAUGHT US A LOT.
THEY THANKED DENNIS FOR PUTTING
THIS TOGETHER.
THAT'S THE JOY THAT WE GET OUT
OF THIS.
>> AND I WISH YOU GOOD LUCK AND
EFFECTIVENESS.
I WISH YOU GOOD LUCK AND
EFFECTIVENESS IN INFLUENCING THE
PEOPLE THERE.
DENNIS, LET ME END ON THIS.
YOU DO HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THIS MAN.
YOU'VE SAID IT MANY TIMES.
>> YES.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY IF YOU GET IT TO
SPEAK UP FOR THE FAMILY OF
KENNETH BAE AND SAY, LET US KNOW
WHY THIS MAN IS BEING HELD?
IF YOU CAN HELP THEM, WILL YOU
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY?
>> WATCH THIS.
THE ONE THING ABOUT POLITICS,
KENNETH BAE DID ONE THING, IF
YOU UNDERSTAND -- IF YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT KENNETH BAE DID,
DO YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT HE DID?
>> WHAT DID HE DO?
YOU TELL ME.
>> IN HIS COUNTRY.
>> YOU TELL ME.
YOU TELL ME.
WHY IS HE HELD CAPTIVE.
>> THEY HAVEN'T RELEASED ANY
CHARGES.
THEY HAVEN'T RELEASED ANY
REASON.
>> LISTEN.
LISTEN.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO SPEAK ON
THIS.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU GOTTEN GUYS
HERE -- TEN GUYS HERE THAT HAVE
LEFT THEIR FAMILIES, LEFT THEY
FAMILIES TO HELP THIS COUNTRY IN
A SPORTS VENTURE.
TEN GUYS, ALL THESE GUYS HERE.
DO ANYONE UNDERSTAND THAT?
>> WE DO.
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT.
>> CHRISTMAS -- I DON'T GIVE
[ BLEEP ] LOOK AT THESE GUYS.
LOOK AT THEM.
>> DON'T USE THEM AS AN EXCUSE
FOR THE BEHAVIOR THAT YOU'RE
PUTTING ON YOURSELF.
YOU JUST BASICALLY WERE SAYING
THAT KENNETH BAE DID SOMETHING
WRONG.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE
CHARGES ARE.
>> LISTEN.
LISTEN.
>> I GOT IT.
LET ME DO THIS.
LET ME -- LET ME.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU ONE THING.
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD --
AROUND THE WORLD -- I'M GOING TO
DO ONE THING.
YOU DON'T DIE BEHIND THE MIC
RIGHT NOW.
THE GUYS HERE DO ONE THING.
WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO AMERICA
AND TAKE THE ABUSE.
WE GOING TO TAKE.
DO YOU, SIR, LET ME KNOW -- WE
GOING TO GET IT.
BUT GUESS WHAT THOUGH?
ONE DAY, ONE DAY THIS DUDE IS
GOING TO OPEN BECAUSE THESE TEN
GUYS HERE, ALL OF US, CHRISTY,
DENNIS, CHARLES, EVERYBODY HERE,
IF WE COULD JUST OPEN THE DOOR
JUST A LITTLE BIT FOR PEOPLE TO
COME HERE AND DO ONE THING --
>> AND DENNIS MAKES A GREAT
POINT.
THERE ARE OTHER AMERICANS HERE
ON THIS TRIP.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
WE'RE NOT ALONE.
WE'RE IN PASSAGE WITH ABOUT 50
PEOPLE.
THEY'RE HERE ON THE TOUR.
WE'VE INTERACTED WITH THEM AS
WELL.
THE KEY IS YOU CAN BAIT DENNIS.
>> CHARLES -- CHARLES, THAT'S
NOT MY INTENTION.
>> THAT'S NOT --
>> THAT'S NOT MY INTENTION --
>> LET ME FINISH.
IF THAT'S NOT YOUR INTENTION,
WE'RE SAID NUMEROUS TIMES THAT
WE'RE NOT HERE FOR ANY POLITICAL
ASPECTS.
WE'RE NOT HERE TO TALK POLITICS.
SO OUTSIDE OF THAT, ANY
QUESTIONS THAT COME BACK THROUGH
THAT IS BATHING TO GET US --
BAIT ING TO GET IS INTO
POLITICS.
>> CHARLES, I UNDERSTAND IT AS
WELL.
I WISH YOU GOOD LUCK WITH THE
CULTURAL